[Música]
una doble tragedia está viviendo Siria
si el mismo país que lleva en guerra más
de una década y del que poco o nada
volvimos a hablar los medios de
comunicación culpa de nosotros tuvo que
venir una serie de terremotos
destructivos para recordarnos sobre la
existencia y las dificultades que está
viviendo este país de oriente medio el
mundo entero respondió a la crisis
debido a estos terremotos pero una buena
parte de la ayuda llegó fue a Turquía
país que ha sufrido la peor parte de la
devastación después de los después de
los sismos pero Siria además de la
destrucción por estos terremotos el país
ya estaba con una infraestructura
sumamente deficiente con hospitales en
ruinas y diferentes zonas en manos de
grupo rebeldes en donde es prácticamente
imposible acceder muchas críticas
llovieron sobre la comunidad
internacional y sobre las grandes
organizaciones internacionales como por
ejemplo la Organización de las Naciones
Unidas que de hecho
un mea culpa por su lenta respuesta para
ayudar a Siria
creemos que los errores están
corrigiendo ahora pero claramente no se
pueden arreglar todos los problemas que
tuvimos al inicio Aunque ahora la ayuda
está llegando es importante que tengamos
más recursos que tengamos asistencia
transfronteriza como mencioné nuestros
esfuerzos están en ayudar al pueblo
sirio
recientemente el gobierno sirio
encabezado por el presidente bashara
lazat permitió que la ONU abriera Dos
cruces fronterizos con Turquía esto
después de que el Consejo de Seguridad
denunciara justamente la demora en el
acceso a las zonas que están controladas
por los grupos Rebeldes para prestar
asistencia una semana después de los
terremotos y habiendo llegado algo de
ayuda humanitaria a Siria hay que buscar
mecanismos para garantizar la ayuda
humanitaria en este país porque la
destrucción que dejó el terremoto pues
ya dejó una huella pero la guerra
y la crisis humanitaria se mantiene
justamente por el conflicto por lo menos
Martin griffins plantea ese escenario
Pero qué tan posible y factible es
luego de las operaciones de búsqueda y
rescate sigue otra fase humanitaria dar
urgentemente albergue a los
sobrevivientes atención psicosocial
alimentación escolarización y sentido de
futuro esa es nuestra obligación ahora
Bueno entonces así las cosas quedan
varias preguntas sobre la mesa Por qué
el mundo se olvidó de Siria un país que
tiene un conflicto abierto desde hace
más de 10 años esta serie de terremotos
entonces servirá para volver a poner a
Siria en el escenario internacional Cómo
pueden también las partes que están
involucradas en este conflicto
aprovechar esta oportunidad estamos
hablando de Los Rebeldes de Turquía de
Rusia del mundo occidental y por
supuesto el presidente bachar a la Sad y
también Rusia también se pregunta uno si
le servirá esto en cierta forma a el
lavado de imagen al presidente bachar al
azar que tiene pues
está implicado en este conflicto y tiene
una imagen internacional muy atropellada
a lo largo de estos últimos años por la
forma como manejó y la respuesta que dio
a esta guerra civil que comenzó en este
país de medio oriente hace más de una
década avivará esta situación
humanitaria nuevamente el conflicto o
ayudará a mitigarlo o ayudará a ponerle
fin son algunos de los escenarios que
también se puede plantear uno a futuro
por eso hoy en el debate de France 24
Siria de la guerra a la catástrofe para
analizar este tema hemos invitado a
Lourdes Baeza ella es analista
internacional fue corresponsal durante
varios años en la zona de medio oriente
y también está con nosotros Karen barón
ellas corresponsal en medio oriente y
África del Norte es analista geopolítica
e integrante del centro Part para
periodismo y trauma Le recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar todos sus
comentarios a través de las diferentes
redes sociales estamos en Twitter
también en Facebook en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios numeral el debate f-24
todo pegado todo junto y también a mí me
encuentran en Twitter como arroba
santilogo no olviden también que todos
los contenidos de este programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn aprovecho para
saludar a las personas que nos escuchan
día a día a través de estas plataformas
disponibles en podcast
pues no siendo más comienzo entonces con
nuestras invitadas para darles paso
comienzo Entonces por Lourdes bienvenida
Lourdes al programa Gracias por estar
con nosotros hoy aquí en el debate de
France 24 y antes de hablar de la ayuda
humanitaria de lo que ha venido para
Siria a lo largo de esta última semana
mi pregunta para El Punto de partida es
por qué la comunidad se olvidó de Siria
Qué pasó porque incluso los medios de
comunicación dejamos de reportar sobre
los hechos que tienen lugar allí en un
país que está en un conflicto abierto
qué tal Saludos bueno evidentemente la
comunidad internacional no es que se
haya olvidado de Siria es que es una
zona infinitamente más complicada de
para acceder incluso a la hora de cubrir
una información como es la guerra ha
habido muchísimos problemas Muchos
medios de comunicación directamente han
optado por no enviar allí a sus enviados
especiales por cuestiones de seguridad
es una zona plagada de grupos armados no
solamente
por los enfrentamientos entre el
gobierno y Los Rebeldes sirios no
olvidemos que hay parte de lisis grupos
de Al qaeda y otros grupos islámicos que
realmente hacen muy muy complicado
cubrir y saber realmente de primera mano
lo que está pasando en la zona
prácticamente toda la información que
nos ha llegado Durante este tiempo de
oscuridad informativa podemos decir ha
sido de organizaciones que ya estaban
sobre el terreno y que han sido las
primeras en poder ayudar en esta
catástrofe sin tener los medios por
supuesto porque como decís toda la zona
ya estaba muy devastada por la guerra y
esto pues ha terminado de hacer la
situación infinitamente más dura y más
complicada para todos
Karen también le doy la bienvenida al
programa y el mismo Punto de partida la
misma pregunta
Lourdes dice que tal vez la comunidad
internacional no se olvidó de Siria ella
explica los factores de Por qué ha
mermado digamos este flujo de
información sobre el país Pero cuál es
su perspectiva nos olvidamos de este
país que tiene un conflicto abierto le
dimos importancia a otro tipos de
situaciones a nivel mundial qué fue lo
que pasó
Santiago en mí una de las cosas que más
me llamó la atención ante tu
presentación fue precisamente eso
nuevamente aparece Siria el en la escena
o en el escenario
internacional a partir de esta
catástrofe pero creo que también Más
allá de lo que comentó muy acertadamente
Lourdes hubo factores Como por ejemplo
el a partir del
2019-2020 se nos fue casi imposible
poder cubrir en el terreno ese conflicto
u otros por una cuestión específicamente
que tiene que ver con el Coby 19 por lo
tanto no solamente se invisibilizó Siria
o no se pudo cubrir en el terreno sino
también muchos otros conflictos entonces
a partir de este hecho absolutamente
trágico con veinte millones de personas
de población Siria con gravísimos
problemas de seguridad alimentaria
desplazados internos refugiados
el rebrote del cólera sumado al Coby 19
o sea una situación
humanitaria que se que califica como de
estrés humanitario porque se llega a
límites después de estamos esto este
conflicto comenzó en marzo de 2011
estamos en febrero de 2023 ya se habían
empezado a hacer análisis de lo que
podría suceder en el 2023 y se agrega
esta situación es muy probable que esta
visibilización que lo más importante
como punto primigenio es que sirva a la
población civil a los inocentes a las
víctimas inocentes tanto del conflicto
como de la catástrofe catástrofe porque
las sanciones no perjudican al gobierno
como lo hemos estado observando no están
perjudicando a una a una administración
en particular claro están perjudicando a
los seres menos inocentes Claro si esto
fuera de otra manera pues el gobierno de
bachar arazá Tal vez no estaría todavía
en el poder hago la ronda la inversa
Karen continuó con usted y ya le doy la
palabra a Lourdes y creo que es
importante poner el contexto ustedes ya
han dicho y han mencionado la parte
humanitaria Y cómo estaba la sociedad
antes del terremoto cómo estaba la
situación humanitaria el brote de cólera
el brote de de covid 19 y también la
deficiencia en la infraestructura los
edificios destruidos los servicios
públicos y todo esto pero a nivel
político y de presencia de grupos y del
gobierno cómo estaba repartido el país
hasta el terremoto porque esto puede
este hecho este fenómeno natural puede
llegar incluso a reconfigurar muchas
cosas en el conflicto que ya lo vamos a
ver más adelante adelante Karen
si precisamente porque se reduce este
conflicto como una guerra civil una
guerra interna Y eso es erróneo porque
hay muchísimos actores externos a Siria
en este conflicto Siria es un jugador
más en el tablero de ajedrez de la
geopolítica mundial pero empezamos a
observar todos los actores que están
involucrados en este conflicto y tenemos
desde Rusia hasta Turquía desde Turquía
hasta Israel países de occidente países
del Mundo árabe que se han involucrado
directamente entonces simplificarlo una
guerra civil es de alguna manera
desinformar y se puede hacer muy fácil
eh hablar de que esto tiene que ver con
la geopolítica y que tiene que ver con
la geoestrategia y con recursos y con
posicionamientos
geopolíticos y geoestratégicos
son tanto los actores del conflicto y
son tanto las instancias que producido
que
en Por qué no se Avanza en el conflicto
hacia una solución hubo los acuerdos de
Sochi Los acuerdos de hastaná Sí por
ejemplo entre Rusia y Turquía pero no sé
se habían comprometido a zonas de
militarizadas tenemos que focalizar a mí
me parece que lo más fácil sería decir
que hay dos sirias una Siria un bueno
todo un territorio que se denomina Siria
que es soberano basándonos en el derecho
internacional dividido en dos partes uno
bajo la administración del gobierno
central de vallada lasad y otro que se
concentra en la provincia de
donde hay más de cuatro millones de
personas de población civil donde allí
se encuentran alianzas como las
deam que son ex miembros de al qaeda y
hay que tener en cuenta que al caer es
considerado un grupo terrorista por
Naciones Unidas y por la comunidad
internacional y por todos los países
entonces quién queda quién queda en el
medio Santiago siempre está quedando la
gente en el medio la población claro y
con muchos actores externos muchos
actores externos jugando y sin
resolución para la población civil local
que son más sufrientes Lourdes su
perspectiva cómo estaba este país
entonces antes de el terremoto
exactamente como dice Karen lo fácil es
plantearlo en términos de una guerra
civil Pero eso se aleja totalmente de la
realidad sobre el terreno de hecho uno
de los problemas que ha habido a la hora
de asistir a la población Siria Es que
la parte afectada principalmente es la
zona fronteriza con Turquía que es la
zona donde más grupos armados y
diferentes facciones se concentran no
solamente los Rebeldes en contra del
gobierno de basharelasad como decía
Karen sino también ramas de al qaeda de
lisis todo esto en la provincia al oeste
de la provincia de por ejemplo es muy
difícil que llegue la ayuda precisamente
porque el control de esos grupos
islamistas es donde se concentra ahora
mismo en la zona por ejemplo todo lo que
es alepo la zona fronteriza con la parte
de hatay gaciantec esa parte de Siria
está controlada por los Rebeldes pero
también hay una zona de la que nadie
habla donde se asientan los kurdos
tradicionalmente han reclamado su propio
estado y que tradicionalmente han sido
también un problema para Turquía también
como decía Karen sobre todo a raíz yo
creo de la entrada de Rusia en el
conflicto sirio ha habido un punto de
inflexión porque es cuando realmente se
ha visto que derribar el gobierno de
bashar El asad no iba a ser tan fácil y
bueno mucha gente puede pensar que el
conflicto se había estancado pero bajo
mi punto de vista yo creo que también
por el parón de la pandemia y sobre todo
porque en cierto modo también se han
desviado muchos recursos a la Guerra de
Ucrania puede parecer que se haya
estancado el conflicto pero el conflicto
no se ha estancado de hecho si algo ha
puesto de manifiesto esta crisis es que
al final organizaciones internacionales
como la ONU no han tenido más remedio
que negociar con el régimen de basar El
asad pese a las sanciones y Pese a que
durante muchos años ha sido entre
comillas el para la comunidad
internacional porque se han dado cuenta
que si no no había otra manera de ayudar
a la población Siria el único paso que
estaba abierto hasta ahora el de
babalsawa babal jagua ni siquiera estaba
abierto está abierto bajo un acuerdo en
el consejo de seguridad de Naciones
Unidas que el pasado mes de enero pudo
renovarse por supuesto pues con la que
esencia de Rusia como dice Karen hay
muchísimos actores Implicados En el
conflicto hay que verlo dentro del
tablero internacional y un tablero
internacional que está infinitamente más
complicado que anteriormente
principalmente por la batalla que se
está librando a nivel internacional en
suelo ucraniano claro que también es un
es un frente de batalla bastante
complicado Lourdes en ese tablero
internacional que usted describe tenemos
al presidente bazar al asad Y esa
fundamental de este tablero que estamos
analizando de Siria aquí este terremoto
trae una oportunidad para el presidente
a las hadas esta visibilidad que está
teniendo nuevamente Siria a nivel
internacional
vemos incluso que se ha despertado
cierta
simpatía o cierta empatía digamos lo
mejor por la situación que está viviendo
Siria a raíz de los terremotos por
ejemplo caso Arabia Saudita ha enviado
35 toneladas de ayuda humanitaria y es
justamente un país que ha señalado a
nivel internacional ha criticado Avatar
a la SAT pero le ha atendido la mano
debido a la situación aquí al azar tiene
el sartén por el mango o como dicen en
España la sartén o el sartén dependiendo
si estamos en América Latina o en España
para una oportunidad en su beneficio o
para el país cómo lo vio usted
claro sobre todo a la hora de volver a
tener contacto a nivel internacional y
que vuelva a ser reconocido aunque no le
guste a la comunidad internacional y en
un momento dado hayan querido quitarlo
de en medio al final si algo ha puesto
de manifiesto la guerra de Siria es que
todo eso igual que las sanciones las
sanciones como bien decía Karen
solamente acaban afectando a la
población civil porque el régimen no ha
quedado debilitado para nada Y si algo
ha puesto de manifiesto esa llegada de
ayuda usted hablaba de la llegada de
ayuda de Arabia saudí que si no recuerdo
mal uno de los aviones aterrizó
directamente en el aeropuerto de alepo
una de las cosas que no se nos pueden
olvidar es que cuando se trata de tener
ayuda temprana las vías las principales
vías de comunicación en este caso en
Siria y lo más rápido evidentemente es
acudir al gobierno sirio porque son los
que controlan las principales carreteras
que unen Damasco con el norte del país
porque ha venido ayuda también de otros
países como de Irán de Irak de casi
todos los países limítrofes incluso de
Armenia y de lugares que que no ha sido
fácil entre otras cosas porque los
únicos puertos por ejemplo que había
disponibles También tenemos que tener en
cuenta el que hubo un temporal había mal
tiempo tampoco era fácil hacer llegar la
ayuda además de la destrucción que hay
en el país pues por ejemplo el puerto de
la taquia que es uno de los más cercanos
a la zona del seísmo estaba cerrado por
temporal en el lado Turco pasaban lo
mismo con la antigua tartessos entonces
todo esto son factores que van sumando y
a la hora de distribuir la ayuda pues
realmente complican muchísimo la
situación sobre el terreno cosas tan
obvias como que para llevar la ayuda
hacen falta camiones y esos camiones
necesitan combustible Pues en un
escenario de Guerra El combustible no
está tan a mano esa logística es la que
ha complicado realmente la situación y
evidentemente va a ser el asad sacar de
ello porque en este momento
efectivamente en ese sentido tiene la
sartén por el mango él ha distribuido o
ha canalizado casi toda la ayuda
procedente de Países Árabes de India
como digo de Armenia de kazajstán pero
claro no se nos puede olvidar que la
ayuda donde tiene que llegar es a la
frontera que es esa zona que está
controlada por los Rebeldes sirios otras
zonas por
grupos islamistas incluso por la zona
kurda entonces también hay mucho interés
en ayudar pero
sin que eso pueda suponer otro punto de
inflexión en la guerra es decir ellos
han hecho pública una lista de elementos
que están prohibidos porque creen que
habrá grupos que intenten utilizar
también esta situación para reforzarse o
esa entrada de ayuda Karen le pregunto
Esto me lleva este comentario de Lourdes
justamente a preguntar bueno por esta
visibilidad que está teniendo el
presidente de la SAT que puede
capitalizar a su favor pero también como
estos grupos Rebeldes pueden aprovechar
esta visibilidad para para recibir
reconocimiento no solamente publicidad y
hablarse de ellos a nivel mundial sino
que organismos internacionales tengan
que interactuar con ellos a nivel
internacional son reconocidos como los
grupos o los mandatarios de estas
regiones o quienes controlan estas
regiones aquí a nivel político se le
pone un poco de para arriba para los
organismos internacionales y
humanitarios al reconocer a esos
Rebeldes como la autoridad de estas
regiones
Claro Lo que pasa que el discurso es
sumamente complejo y Lourdes Y yo que
hemos estado y que estamos en el terreno
en forma permanente vemos
cómo hay el arte del engaño en el
terreno y el arte del del engaño en el
lenguaje Por qué se va a a convertir en
un actor válido un grupo terrorista como
lo dije anteriormente declarado por
porque son grupos terroristas yihadistas
los que además están manipulando y
utilizan con suetudinariamente y esto lo
hemos visto a través de de estas dos
décadas a la población Entonces por un
lado podemos tener un impacto en cuanto
a partir de la diplomacia humanitaria un
impacto en la diplomacia política como
habló Lourdes anteriormente Y con toda
esta ayuda que llegó de los Países
Árabes que inclusive de muchos países
árabes que inclusive estaban
de la administración de vallada lazada y
por el otro lado Hay que llegar a otras
negociaciones Pero no por eso
reconocerlos porque si no estamos
avalando a grupos que generan terror y
que también tienen También tienen como
Rehenes a la población civil entonces
todo es como muy delicado por eso hablo
de cuidar el lenguaje
por eso por un lado y por el otro
también hemos visto a través del tiempo
lo complejo Que es para los inocentes
que llegue la ayuda que se requiere
porque sí son utilizados por diferentes
facciones tanto estatales como no
estatales y al margen de la ley y
podemos hacer una larga lista donde hay
por eso hay tanta desconfianza porque es
momento para ingresar armamentos para
ingresar
combatientes Entonces el inocente la
víctima está revictimizada en forma
constante pero no creo que sea un
momento para legitimar como han hecho en
durante Algunos años diferentes grupos
porque no lo son y no tienen legitimidad
no tiene legitimidad reitero acusándonos
en el en el derecho internacional y
también otra cosa que que me parece que
que lo tenemos que reflexionar desde
muchas aristas está las sanciones contra
Siria es decir contra el pueblo sirio no
es contrabayar al azar contra la
administración de azar porque claramente
Como dijo Lourdes no han tenido
resultado comienzan en 1979 es un
paquete de dos mil seiscientas sanciones
se reforzó en el año 2019 se la denomina
ley César la César Siria me parece que
es tiempo
con diferentes Fuentes estaba hablando
que es tiempo de reformular si vamos a
tener una vamos a ser respetuosos del
derecho internacional humanitario o si
vamos a tener dobles triples o
variados discursos como los que
escuchamos en forma constante porque por
un lado manifestamos algo me
manifestamos me refiero a a los
políticos y a la comunidad internacional
y y otros actores y por el otro lado
hacemos algo totalmente diferente
entonces para reconstruir por ejemplo
algo que se dañó se llega a una
negociación ahora para llevar ayuda
humanitaria
bueno es Hay que llegar a acuerdos de
pase politiza y lo que se está haciendo
y hay que evitar Y nosotros creo que
tenemos con nuestra responsabilidad
social Mostrar esto es se está
politizando la ayuda humanitaria no es
en el único conflicto ni en la única
situación pero
justamente
vulnerando todo lo que tiene que ver con
el derecho internacional humanitario se
politiza la ayuda humanitaria Más allá
de aquellos de los actores del conflicto
Y de quién está en ese momento
gobernando claro y por eso Muchos
actores han dudado un poco a la hora de
actuar frente a la crisis Siria no
solamente ahora por los terremotos sino
también en los últimos meses por Ese
temor a que se politice y dada la
dificultad que hay también con el con el
propio gobierno por esas sanciones a
nivel internacional y por ese
señalamiento que haya el presidente al
azar pero el presidente las hadas es el
que está dentro del marco de la ley
Siria pues es el presidente después de
un proceso electoral que también ha sido
muy criticado a nivel internacional Pero
dentro del marco de la ley es el
presidente esto no sé si ustedes tienen
este temor y aquí meto un poco yo mi
opinión que no lo suelo hacer en el
programa Lourdes pero no temen ustedes
que lleguemos a ese escenario donde al
azar se vuelva el Aliado de la comunidad
internacional y sea ese canalizador
tanto de la ayuda humanitaria como de la
ayuda militar para darle Digamos como un
respiro a la guerra y abrir un un
segundo capítulo en el conflicto sirio
para combatir a estos rebeldes en el en
el norte del país cómo lo ven ustedes
Lourdes
Bueno yo realmente no creo que se vaya a
convertir tanto en un Aliado como en una
figura que no queda más remedio que
tolerar
parte de lo que
decía Karen hay que tenerlo muy en
cuenta porque no olvidemos que todos los
acuerdos de ayuda que se están llevando
a cabo en estos días bajo mi punto de
vista son relativamente cortoplacistas
es decir
babal jagua el paso que habitualmente
está abierto el único paso que está
abierto entre Turquía y Siria
se renueva cada seis meses el mandato
Los acuerdos que acaban de cerrar tanto
Turquía como Siria para abrir esos otros
dos pasos de los que hablábamos
tanto dar el salam como al rey va a
estar abierto durante tres meses cuando
estamos hablando de una zona totalmente
devastada de millones de personas que ya
no tenían nada pero lo poco que tenían
además lo han perdido no olvidemos
muchas de las personas tanto en el sur
de Turquía como en el norte de Siria son
desplazados sirios es decir hay mucha
gente que también estaba del otro lado
de la frontera muchos sirios en el lado
Turco que lo poco que tenían también lo
han perdido y hay mucha gente que ni
siquiera estaba lo que podríamos Llamar
censada es decir hay mucha gente que no
hay constancia ni de sus movimientos ni
de que estuvieran en ciertos sitios con
lo cual en esta catástrofe yo creo que
las cifras van a ser realmente las
peores de la historia de un de un
terremoto en la zona y no creo que con
acuerdos a tres meses se vaya a
solucionar realmente nada va a echar el
asado evidentemente lo va a rentabilizar
porque yo creo que ya lo está
rentabilizando de hecho gran parte de
esos países que han enviado ayuda se han
mantenido al margen totalmente del
conflicto y esto ha hecho que en cierto
modo retomen relaciones con lo cual es
un paso también se puede utilizar como
esa ayuda para politizar la ayuda y para
dar un vuelco a nivel político
internacional claro No sé hasta qué
punto eso va a hacer aceptar la figura
de bashar El asad pero sí tengo Claro
que la población civil no está en el
foco principal que es como debería estar
y sobre todo que no sea calibrado la
magnitud todavía de esta catástrofe y el
devenir de esa gente que actualmente
está en tiendas de campaña si nos
fijamos en las imágenes y por lo que
hablamos con gente que está en la zona
la mayoría de esas tiendas vienen o de
Turquía o de la cooperación catarí pero
hace falta algo más hace falta
restablecer suministros que ya de por sí
no estaban no estaban operativos en
muchas de las zonas de guerra Me quedan
pocos minutos para finalizar el programa
pero tengo dos preguntas importantes en
la primera les pido por favor que sea un
poco más puntuales para que abarquemos
los dos temas Karen dado este escenario
ustedes hablan de la gran magnitud que
tiene esto a nivel humanitario esta
catástrofe que todavía pues es imposible
de evidenciar en su magnitud por
completo Esto va a generar nuevamente
una crisis humanitaria refugiados de
sirios ahora también se suman turcos
huyendo de esta zona del desastre hacia
Europa es decir podemos ver en el verano
boreal una crisis humanitaria debido a
esta catástrofe natural
mente esta situación de catástrofe
humanitaria se va a intensificar pero no
creo teniendo en cuenta los antecedentes
de
movimientos migratorios anteriores de
refugiados hacia Europa que se dirijan
hacia Europa o que sean aceptados
masivamente en Europa y sobre todo por
el contexto en el cual estamos
estamos transitando que es el conflicto
entre Rusia y Ucrania donde ya se se
absorbió y lo digo
en forma humanitaria una gran cantidad
de de refugiados ucranianos
lo que sí esto se va a intensificar un
punto que hay que Resaltar es hay una
tal cantidad de muertos en este momento
esa cantidad de Muertos va a aumentar
cantidad de heridos esos esa cantidad de
heridos va a aumentar esas carpas
hablaba Lourdes pueden pasar años
nosotras conocemos carpas que hace diez
doce años que están aún bajo la bandera
de abnuro de Naciones Unidas o cualquier
otra organización pero más allá de de
esta pregunta en específico estamos
transitando a nivel geopolítico un mundo
totalmente diferente por lo tanto hay
que ver cómo se posiciona Siria con esta
ayuda del todo puede pasar no hay amigos
permanentes en la geopolítica ni en la
política intereses permanentes claro Hay
hubo una ayuda inmediata de Países
Árabes y de otros países
quizás se estuvo hablando que quizás se
incorpore nuevamente la liga árabe pero
tienen presión de los sus aliados los
Países Árabes de El sus aliados de
occidente pero todo puede pasar porque
todo está cambiando a una velocidad y a
un ritmo muy rápido claro y esto impacta
estas decisiones políticas ya en las en
la vida directa de los seres humanos
Lourdes muy puntual por favor esto como
todo está encadenado todos estos hechos
están Encadenados este terremoto esta
situación en el sur de Turquía este
nuevo surgimiento de Siria a nivel
internacional esto que repercusión tiene
en el conflicto en el don vast en la
guerra en Ucrania porque los actores son
prácticamente los mismos y hay que
destacar ese papel que tiene Turquía
como un mediador entre kiev y Moscú
ahora pues Le tocará hacer frente a su
situación interna que es muy grave y
sobre todo con el escenario de las
elecciones presidenciales en unos meses
Exactamente eso es lo que iba a comentar
que no solamente por el escenario a
nivel interno sino porque en junio
erdogan tiene que enfrentarse a las
urnas si es que finalmente pues debido a
esta situación no se retrasa Y eso va a
ser también una fecha muy importante
porque de ahí va a depender también en
gran medida el devenir de los
acontecimientos en la zona y sobre todo
Pues cuando hablamos de refugiados y de
posibles nuevas oleadas hacia Europa yo
creo que Turquía está conteniendo a los
refugiados también la ayuda europea está
ayudando mucho a que Turquía haga ese
papel pero claro tampoco sabemos cómo
puede afectar esta crisis políticamente
a erdogan y ni lo que puede venir
después y eso va a ser el mes de lo que
pase en junio si realmente se celebran
las elecciones tal y como están
previstas va a cambiar también la
situación en la zona como decía antes yo
creo que sí que se han desviado muchos
recursos a la Guerra de Ucrania y eso
también ha afectado al conflicto sirio
veremos Cómo evolucionan tanto la una
como la otra porque la Guerra de Ucrania
tampoco parece que vaya a acabar en dos
días Sí parece que se prolonga más de lo
que teníamos esperado todos en la
comunidad internacional Karen para el
cierre por favor 50 segundos su
respuesta a esta pregunta que usamos a
modo de conclusión del cierre del
programa
al cierre del programa la conclusión es
que tengamos una mayor información más
acabada más certera por nuestro derecho
a la información y uno puede decir qué
tiene que ver con Siria Porque si
limitamos la información a cuestiones
muy básicas y muy simples no podemos
entender lo que sucede en ese país en
esa región y lo que está sucediendo a
nivel global a nivel global que está
teniendo impacto en todo el el globo
terráqueo y generando conflictos
absolutamente nuevos Como por ejemplo la
Primera Guerra
híbrida Mundial o el la Primera Guerra
financiera o económica mundialista me
pueden decir qué tiene que ver Siria
tiene que ver con Siria todo porque
también es un actor del conflicto que
está apoyado por otros actores
fundamentales en una en un conflicto que
desencadenó
de guerras que acabo de de nombrar y por
favor no mezclemos los temas políticos
con los humanitarios Aunque sí los
políticos los mezclan Así que
focalícenos allí Karen Lourdes un
verdadero gusto haberlas tenido hoy en
el programa haber hecho análisis con
ustedes de esta situación allí en Siria
y el medio oriente en general a raíz de
estos conflictos que han venido a lo
largo de los últimos años y de estos
terremotos recientes Muchísimas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros En nombre
del equipo técnico también Les
agradecemos a ustedes la sintonía la
producción del programa estuvo a cargo
de Laura garzón y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera ustedes pueden seguir dejando
sus comentarios a través de las redes
sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]